this group of pennsylvania college
students flew to los angeles for their
spring holiday
but the soaring price of fuel has put a
crimp in their plans for fun in the
california sun
water bee landed from the airport and i
saw the gas prices i was like
fuel has been expensive for months due
to a pandemic induced shortfall in
supply but russia's attack on ukraine
spooked markets and turbocharged prices
the oil market reacts much like the
stock market and unfortunately drivers
are paying for that at the gas pump high
priced fuel makes the price of
everything transported by road sea and
air more expensive driving up inflation
even further the average price of
gasoline in the u.s is hovering at about
four dollars a gallon that's 3.7 liters
california is the state with the highest
gasoline prices
5.31
on average but in some places like here
in beverly hills it costs a lot more
than that
the u.s and other governments are trying
to cushion the blow by releasing fuel
from strategic reserves we don't know
how long this is going to last
but
we are
very focused
on right now alleviating pain at the
pump to the extent we can prices will
likely remain high for the foreseeable
future the u.s energy information agency
says oil will stay above 100 a barrel
for the rest of the year at four dollars
a gallon is that a point where people
can't take it anymore it still remains
to be seen but inevitably we think we
might see some behavioral change belt
tightening is already one of brittany
anderson's plans it's definitely going
to factor in how i am budgeting for my
rent and my groceries
paying off my debts i was not
anticipating this big of a hit a hit to
americans pocket books from a war half a
world away
rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles